- This video was made
possible by Tab for a Cause.
If you are a subscriber to this channel,
you are a Legal Eagle,
that means you want to know
how the laws that govern our
everyday lives actually work.
You know that the world is complicated
and you're not willing to
settle for the easy answers
that pundits love to provide.
You believe that understanding
the law is crucial
to being an informed citizen
and you are not willing to turn away,
even when you get answers
that you don't like.
You're here to think like a lawyer.
So, my fellow Legal Eagles,
in 2019, I say to you,
(fireworks blasting)
caw-caw.
(eagle screeching)
And if you're looking for
more killer legal analysis,
I thought it might be
helpful to make a list
of the five best attorneys
to follow in 2019.
Fair warning, this list is
gonna be pretty politics-heavy,
because I think that those are some
of the most important
legal issues of the day,
maybe that will change in 2020,
but that's where we are now.
So let' start out with
an honorable mention,
who is not actually a lawyer,
but who's legal analysis
is so good that I almost
included him on this list
and that's Ben Wittes of the Lawfare blog.
He's not a lawyer,
he's a little bit on
the conservative side,
but in my view, nobody knows more
about National Security
law on the internet today.
And as Mr Wittes likes to point out,
democratic norms are being
broken all over the place
in this current world that we live in,
but it's bringing people together
from all over the political spectrum.
I share Mr Wittes' request
that when this is all over,
everyone remember the
shared democratic principles
that brought us together
in these trying times.
So definitely check out Ben Wittes
and the entire Lawfare blog
and podcast community, they are great.
(heavy rock music)
So that brings us to fifth place
for the top lawyers to follow in 2019
and that goes to Leonard French.
Moving away from politics for the moment,
as your second favorite
Copyright Attorney,
I can highly recommend your first favorite
Copyright Attorney, Leonard French.
Leonard French is a Copyright
Attorney and YouTuber
known for wearing funny hats,
while he gives great legal analysis,
he tends to livestream
before he goes to work,
so you can catch him early in
the mornings or late at night,
he often goes straight
into the legal briefs
of famous copyright cases
or other legal cases of
the day and it's great,
because you rarely get a chance
to see the actual language
and paperwork that gets
filed in these things
and he provides great analysis.
His YouTube channel, the Lawful
Masses with Leonard French
is great for copyright news of the day,
especially for video game related news,
it's a little wonky, but
that's how we like it here.
(heavy rock music)
So that takes us to fourth place
and that goes to Seth Abramson.
He is a former state and
federal public defender,
there's going to be a lot
of Assistant US Attorneys
and District Attorneys on this list,
so it's nice to get the
perspective of a public defender.
Currently Seth Abramson focuses
on the Trump Administration
and all of the legal issues
that the administration is facing.
He gets a lot of flack for
not doing original reporting
and for being extremely
long-winded, like Twitter threads
that are hundreds of posts
long, and fair enough,
but for my money, no one is examining
the publicly available evidence
in more detail than Seth Abramson.
Note however, that he tends
to be extremely partisan,
so I would take all of his
analysis with a grain of salt,
maybe dial it back 25 or 30%, but still,
when news cycles don't even last 24 hours,
we need someone to be able to cull through
the deluge of news that
we're getting everyday
and look at things from
a lawyer's perspective
and a lot of the analysis
that Seth Abramson is
doing is really top-notch.
(heavy rock music)
All right, so that takes us to third place
and that goes to two lawyers,
Renato Mariotti and Asha Rangappa,
who are often hosts of
the On Topic podcast.
I mention both, because while the podcast
is Renato Mariotti's, he
often has Asha Rangappa on,
and frankly, the podcast is never better,
than when she provides
her analysis as well.
Both are former Assistant US Attorneys,
which essentially is
like a District Attorney,
but for the Federal government.
Renato worked on the civil side,
while Asha worked on the
counter-intelligence side,
so they're analysis together
is especially invaluable.
You can also find both of them on Twitter,
but they're also not afraid
to do an emergency podcast
to stay on top of this news cycle,
that is burying people in
new things every single day,
so definitely check out
the On Topic podcast.
(heavy rock music)
So that takes us to second place
and that easily goes to Preet Bharara,
who is the host of the Stay Tuned podcast
and tweets @PreetBharara.
Preet Bharara was in charge
of the Southern District of New York,
which is often considered
one of the most prestigious
Federal District courts.
Not only does the Southern
District of New York
tend to handle a lot of
high-profile terrorists
and related cases, because of
the fact that New York City
is in the Southern District of New York,
they also tend to handle almost all
of the very high-profile financial crimes
by virtue of Wall Street being
in the Southern District.
Note that he was a democratic appointee
who was personally fired by the President,
so you'll probably need
to take his analysis
with a grain of salt,
but I think he is one
of the best interviewers
on the planet right now,
you cannot miss his podcast.
(heavy rock music)
So that takes us to number one
and that goes to Ken
White, who tweets @Popehat
and is in charge of All
the President's Lawyers
and the First Amendment
podcast, Make No Law,
Ken White is a former
Assistant US Attorney
turned Defense Attorney,
who's also done a fair amount
of First Amendment law.
He also has a very skeptical view
of government and prosecutorial
power, which I find,
makes his analysis both
accurate and hilarious.
It's hard to describe just how good
Ken White's Twitter account is.
It is, I think, by far, the
best thing on Twitter right now,
so if you're not following
@Popehat on Twitter,
stop everything that you're
doing and subscribe now.
Sometimes it's hard to follow him,
because his handle's always
some variation of hat,
so at the time of this
video, it's Hamberder Hat,
which relates to a President's tweet.
In the past it's been Covfefe
Hat, VeryLegalVeryCool Hat,
his podcast, All the President's Lawyers,
in addition to having the
greatest name for a podcast,
is fantastic, it's hosted
by journalist Josh Barrow,
who does a great job
playing the straight man
to Ken White's legal analysis
and breaking things down
from a layman's perspective.
When I do a podcast, I'm
gonna try and make it
half as good as All the
President's Lawyers.
Ken White is known for taking
a very dim view of the RICO statutes,
please tell him to make
a It's not RICO t-shirt,
because it's not RICO, it's never RICO,
but maybe this time.
(fireworks blasting)
Caw-caw.
(eagle screeching)
So go and check out those lawyers
and while you're browsing the net,
you can raise money for charity,
just by opening new tabs,
which you were going to do anyway.
Tab for a Cause is a
Google Chrome extension
that allows you to pick
a charity of your choice
and then every time you open up a new tab,
instead of it being blank,
it displays a couple of ads
and the money that you generate
is donated to your charity,
there is no charge to you
and it does some good for the world.
Tab for a Cause users have raised
hundreds of thousands
of dollars for charity,
it is the easiest possible
way to donate to charity,
so just click on the
link in the description
and download the extension
and do some good,
by doing what you were going to do anyway.
So did I get that right?
Are there other lawyers that you follow
that you think I should
also follow in 2019?
Let me know and until next
time, I'll see you in court.